it's the people that have that that when  so the market grew before you let's go  in detail like like TechCrunch doesn't  pick the winners right like that's like  you know the Wall Street Journal doesn't  pick the winners three cool kids in the  crowd don't make the winners the problem  is everybody wants to be anointed a  winner or best at what they do before  they've actually done it I would just  remind you and everybody out here  I built a business for 18 hours day  every day running a wine liquor store  for 13 years every day before I ever had  the audacity to come to something like  this and talk so so let me have let me  tell you something I'm basic if you're  good enough you will win but if you were  upset that somebody else's grand Pappy  got them ahead of you then you're going  to lose everybody started ahead of me  I'm just catching up  you  [Music]